hey what's up guys my name is a Jonah
welcome to episode 84 of game
programming so last time we took a look
at creating sprites in After Effects and
today we're gonna continue that so we
created a pretty nice-looking grass
texture let me get rid of this light
because we're clearly not going to use
it and let me enable the lights back on
the wall and meet grass so that's first
of all adjust these slightly get them
back into what they were looking like
before I'm just gonna grab this light
and move it over on the x-axis here and
just you know this is just giving it a
really soft vignette if you look at the
before and after there's quite a
difference here it's kinda making it a
bit darker and it's it's giving it like
a nice kind of patchy soft vignette and
I actually really like that look as for
wall I don't think the light is bright
enough I'm just gonna be honest here if
I got a lot of options here and it's
kind of bluish which is cool might make
it a bit less so and if I go over here
to the verse and intensity I might just
boost that just a little bit here to
give it more of that sort of look
there's still these black kind of areas
here and they don't look into fabulous
so let's go ahead and kind of fix that
out by that I don't know I don't think
it's alive it's doing that though I
think it's just the isn't it okay
alright there we go so that's looking
pretty good right now as far as bricks
go bricks that aren't there top down so
that's going to ask the wall composition
that's wrong isn't it
I'm not gonna fix this contact long I
was looking at this little um gap here
and I'm not there's no way I'm gonna fix
that
so before after walls I mean this was
pretty good to begin with but I think
I'm gonna stick to the new walls okay so
now today we're gonna basically cover I
don't know about these secondary walls I
might just replacing with the primary
walls but we're definitely gonna take a
look at flooring today and that's
probably it's a flooring and these walls
is what we're going to cover in this
episode and in the next episode we're
gonna talk about the player so
composition your composition I'm gonna
call this one flaw again 16 by 16 I know
a lot of you guys asked me to actually
um increase the resolution because last
episode I asked you guys if he wanted me
to increase the resolution of the
textures but I think that I've decided
to not do that just because um like
we've kind of come this far with and
this is really supposed to be like a
kind of like a pixel best game so I
don't want to mess with that but you
know who knows I might get really
tempted to do it and end up doing it so
yeah yeah
anything could happen really anyway um
we'll make a new layer here and I think
I kind of liked um B color that we had
let's grab the color of I'm going to
quickly grab a composite a new solid
here just to get that color probably
this one right here let's copy the hex
the hexadecimal value of that color and
into lay a new solid over here I'm just
gonna paste that into a color probably a
better way of doing that better anyway
that's at the beginning of flaws now
let's take a look at how we can make
flaws in After Effects it really depends
what kind of floor you're going for this
is like a um there's a like I don't even
know what they called in English
floorboards I guess there's like floor
floorboards right you can see the
vertical lines here um that's that's
kind of a nice floor we can definitely
take a look at that so that is really as
simple as probably just darkening areas
of it so what I might do is duplicate
this medium is an orange solid medium
gray orange solid go to cellar settings
and darkness maybe just like that it is
quite orange isn't it okay that looks
pretty good and let's make sure these
are both set onto the right
people thing and then you can say that
we kind of get these little things and I
could add them even every second if I
wanted to
so that's kind of what we can get by
doing that and that is effectively very
similar to this okay now you can see
that there is actually a brighter one
right there and we could do that as well
but there's actually an effect called
flutters pre-compose it's just to
demonstrate it's one concept quickly
there is an effect called scatter eyes
Oh scatter in fact probably scatters
they say scatter eyes no it's not this
one well this one this one kind of does
it too much as you can see but I think
scatter is yes cat is the one that I use
a lot it like it scatters it scatters
pixels and I think it's gonna be really
useful for pixel art to be honest you
can change the grain to be you know
horizontal vertical and the cool thing
about this is that we can really make
some interesting effects with this so if
I come in to floor here and for this
deep orange so I'm just gonna grab the
masks here and set them to non just for
now go back to floor here and let's see
if we can kind of start increasing this
and go back to floor of course and let
me just mask out half of it not with
this mask out like half of it you can
say that we can start getting some
pretty um interesting looking effects
here and they caught the cool thing
about this scatter thing is that you can
actually control whether it's horizontal
vertical or both and you can see how you
can kind of randomize that so that's
really cool for creating them this sort
of stuff with green and you can see that
it kind of just randomized the location
of pixels now that's cool of course it's
a lot more impressive in high
resolutions but that's one way that um I
think I'm gonna utilize this effect here
let's first of all set this to add and I
think what I'm gonna do at this point is
this is I reckon the floors gonna be
pretty basic here nothing nothing too
extravagant let's grab a new solid and
let's grab this color but make it
brighter this time like that you saw in
the other floor and let's hide that
layer for a minute here make sure it's
not anti aliased no no shape layer and
let's probably do this side and this
side
and this side of orion's let's toggle on
the layout said Oh see what that looks
like okay that looks pretty cool so now
we've got kind of three of each yeah and
we're gonna keep doing that so with this
I'm gonna make a another one here and
another one here is that too much yeah
okay and same with this so really this
stuff you could obviously doing paint on
man and I've course messed that up
come on let's grab this one and just
shift it over and this one as well but
the reason I like using After Effects is
for the more advanced stuff again you
know it doesn't really apply to the
floor in this case but that's alright
and I guess we'll grab this deep Orange
I saw it again and duplicate that and
there you go okay so we're looking at a
floor right now looks interesting
doesn't it so once we've done that let's
just drag a few of these out not really
too many just a few well we're not done
with the floor texture by the way before
you start saying that it doesn't look
like it's done it's not done let's just
I just like to pre visualize things as
you could probably tell let's just scale
this up to be the size of that's not
this is gonna be really hard to scale ah
now we can see the edge here all right
so that's nice little I think that's
perfect scaling so 296 seems too big of
a lie to scale by move it here there you
go all right so that's what a new floor
looks like so far
so let's take a look at how we can
improve it let's see
all right so new for new floor versus
old floor all floor has horizontal rims
as you can probably tell as well as
probably mmm I'm just thinking see this
is one way of doing a floor but I don't
think I like this aesthetics very much I
just don't think it works with the game
especially if we're looking at um I
guess a spawn level here with grass I
think wood is nice but I just think that
um this kind of floor board aesthetic
like the floorboards just aren't be you
know I think that's the main problem
here so let's come back into this and
well that's actually I'm just gonna
literally go through every second mask
and probably get rid of it so there's
three that wasn't really every second
mask that's all right um let's grab this
yeah okay so you can see if we do that
we kind of get four BOTS to look like
this if we total of this I wonder if we
could um I just want to what it would
look like if we made some floorboards
that yeah it's probably a good idea
actually let's grab this meeting where I
start I'm just gonna actually that's a
pretty nice color isn't it I just think
it's too too much red in this color in
fact let's not do it through this will
be easier to do it to do this through
curves because we can we can control
each color channel separately of course
we can do that in the RGB stuff as well
but this kind of gives you much just a
better way of editing it so let's go to
the red channel and kind of get rid of
some of that red not too much of course
but just a bit
I think it's there's quite a bit of
green as well so we couldn't don't want
to push that too much that looks pretty
good yeah
and what we want to do here now is I
think I think I want to make this a bit
wider
maybe like that well this is just a mine
to edit okay that's pretty good that's
not gonna look very well as you can say
a bit that's alright I think if we have
to floorboards per frame per sorry um
yes in that case to floorboards that's
going to probably look nice if we go
back to a screenshot here we can tell
what where we kind of rid this up and
there's a way to thin okay there we go
okay cool so we've got something looks
like floorboards here um now I'm going
to actually go to this deep orange solid
and probably not even this let's get rid
of this solid let's duplicate the deep
orange solid get rid of its masks and go
to solid settings and just make it quite
a bit darker here almost and kind of D
saturated so not too saturating here
okay that's probably good and I'm just
gonna grab this and kind of make you
know those are wooden like imperfection
kind of things maybe like one hand
whoops way too big
one here one here okay yeah
and now what I want to do is this is our
background layer again it's on a
separate layer which is great because
I'm now I'm going to add some some
fractals to it so if we got a fractal
noise we could probably just use a
normal noise effect I actually really
need
I think fractals will probably look a
lot better though yeah noise noise just
some great okay so let's go to fractal
noise grab some of that first whoops
first want to pre-crisis layer call it
base block and we need to move all
attributes to the new composition so
base law and allowed some fractal noise
to it okay so you know like last time
first thing were probably gonna do is
just kind of unscaled this contrasts
probably way too high here drop to 50 or
so that should be nice now what else is
there to set bloody mode I mean we could
probably say this too
what is this a bunny right off yeah okay
yeah
I like to play around with this yes it
overlays pretty good right so this
offset will give us a bit of her okay
and I think we want to go for more of a
spline look but soft linear spline and
we could probably up the contrast here
to 70 or so you can say that we're kind
of starting to get some interesting
flooring here in fact I think we could
probably go back to floor and get rid of
these imperfections here you can see
yeah that kinda looks like a pretty
authentic ball I think it's there's too
much fertilization going here I think
also that we don't have it pick slave
know that does make a difference
mm-hmm looks a little more pixelated
here we could smooth it out I guess if
we turn these to smoothy smooth
that's too much smoothing
yeah that completely pixelated yeah I
think no we didn't like that huh that's
weird
they're not really looking the same on
their UK let's focus on this white ham
oh why using the wrong one how quiet
this is which one is this one this one
so then why there's a book different
here we've got the same stuff on no I've
got scatter here whoops okay
so that's what our floors looking like
yeah it's not bad
wonder what we could do to improve this
may be the actual floorboards I think
that what if we were to get rid of these
levers that that wasn't only a little
floor anymore doesn't mmm or what we
could do is add the highlights as well
so we'll make another new solid here
really light color here and make it even
lighter and come in here and do this and
do that
that second one it's over the first one
here
I don't know I don't think these
fractals are working too well with the
floor to be honest I think that um I
think that this low resolution is kind
of ruining them hmm okay we could we
could always blend them and probably
help they can place their doing too much
hmm first smooth it out a bit not a big
fan of these highlights either
and I think the color of this just is
not fitting drive that down a bit and of
course the pixels here on lining up so
what we could do to fix that is let's
complete break and post this as a whole
lot of subfloor and if we go over here
to mirror hope that's not what I wanted
I think we want it like a repeat edges
kind of thing maybe maybe this would
work if we cut off
those are why
let's go into base I'm sorry
sub full going to sub flow and we will
now check that will get rid of a bit of
them
all right and you can say they're
repeating here so if we blend these
borders a bit not too much just a touch
we can um we can kind of get it to look
a lot nicer okay so that's kind of our
floor texture right now again I'm not an
artist so I apologize if you think it
looks terrible
but fair thing is I probably spend a
good hour on this but I'm kind of trying
to make this watchable so I might touch
them up off-camera all righty
all right so that's that now this second
wall I'm thinking if we actually need a
second of all we go on here I mean let's
also grab a light and add it to our wall
sorry to our floor kind of dish that up
and I think that the color here is said
to be blue change that to white all
right kind of Cresson nasty highlight
doesn't it mm-hmm let's go back to here
I think if we do make it kind of bluish
it could just give it a bit of a better
feel maybe not that blue where are we
but just a touch
all right does that floor mmm and for
our final little asset here which is
this I'm just thinking I think I got
really I do kind of like to look at
these walls they look pretty nice don't
they and so their tile really well I
think I might just grab one of them so
again I'll go a composition new
composition or make it 16 by 16 and I
will hit okay and I'll grab our spawn
level to bright yet here and I'll find
these walls here and okay so I might
just um add some lighting to them effect
an artifact lanyu whoops
lanyu light and what kind of going for a
blue field are we are we don't we
that English okay so I'm just kind of
modifying this price to just create a
bit more um of an ambient kind of blue
fuel will probably add some kind of
lighting system into the actual game so
I probably won't have to do this to make
it look nice but this is more of a
pre-visualization thing so comp one I
didn't actually call it anything
and let's
put that here and I think that's the
full one yeah all right so that's kind
of the difference between the old ones
and the new ones yeah this floor I'm not
doing the floor too much I'm digging
this and I am digging the walls in the
grass I didn't make the grass or that
but I think if we just looks to blood I
don't think that Bob what that works
because this is a pixel kind of like a
pixelated game so I think if we just
turn out the contrast here go back to
here we can relate that's very bright
let's down that intensity and are there
any kind of it almost feels like um
there's some color correction going on
look at that it'd be different so it's
just because of the UM the
No okay let's make something that can
tile well out of this floor so contrast
I get a lot of brightness here hmm
what does a floor look like let's um
let's gosh her such a flaw on the google
images and what do we get okay this
looks pretty nice
welcome to sprite making with the Cherno
okay so yeah you can see those patches
if we zoom in a lot
you can see those that's actually seems
to zoom out you can see those um the
things and you can see the patches here
and that looks pretty good
but the problem with this compared to
our thing is our thing has to be 16 by
16 pixels but with that inspiration in
mind let's yes these are out yeah let's
um make this darker
and I think for this gray solid maybe
the base floor we could kind of improve
the color here by going to solid
settings and I think if we push a bit
more red into it just like that and
maybe the scale of this could be
improved just a bit okay we could
actually
non-uniformly scalloped that could be
interesting problem is this probably
isn't gonna on tile too nicely know that
tiles pretty well all right let's keep
it as that okay so now that we've done
this stuff let's um and we've done the
wall as well okay so it's gonna wrap up
this episode of game programming we got
some pretty sick looking redwood floor
that looks like and we've um we've also
modified this wall to just look a bit I
think one more thing I might want to do
with that wall is actually scattered a
bit just a bit just like one pixel cuz
that'll kind of make it look kind of
like ruiny and I think that that could
look really nice as well
kind of like that's falling apart okay
but anyway that's gonna wrap up this
episode of game programming I hope you
guys enjoyed it it was a bit well it's I
mean it's art creations are we gonna say
this stuff kind of takes time and um
it's aesthetical so it's not really it's
not really it's creative thing but
regardless of that if you guys did enjoy
it place it like button again same deal
as last time this video hits 300 likes
you guys get two episodes a per day this
video hits 200 likes we get one episode
per day but far apart from that guys
I'll see you guys soon
very very soon let it guys
you